today we demonstrated that the previous
government's attempt to entrap this
young government into asphyxiating
straitjackets into a very tight schedule
whereby immediately after our election
we had a few short weeks in order to
negotiate for the very first time in the
history of our bailout since 2010
generally to negotiate in good faith but
powerfully and in a committed manner to
negotiate a way out for our country we
combined two things that are usually
imagined to be contradictory we combined
logic and ideology in the way that we
bargained we combined respect for the
rules and respect for democracy we
averted the view that a country that is
heavily indebted and in a problem cannot
possibly claim that elections can change
something we stood up right from the
beginning of the negotiations to the
very end especially when faced by
immense pressure and we showed that we
were committed to skillful negotiations
for the purpose of achieving a mutually
beneficial agreement between us and our
European partners from the very first
day that we got elected we stated
unequivocally this government and I
personally we are not in the business of
short changing our partners we're not in
the business of coming here in a
tug-of-war to say give us something when
you lose something we refuse to look to
look at this negotiation as a zero-sum
game where our gain is somebody else's
loss we genuinely and faithfully
targeted one of
active and that was the interest of the
average European and we believe that
today the agreement that we reached
through this negotiation does place the
interest of the average European above
all else now enough of this
self-congratulation this is time for
work haven't finished all be patient
Savage as you have heard from mr. dizer
bloom whom by the way I want to thank
profusely for the excellent work that he
did today to steer the Eurogroup towards
a successful completion of at least this
phase we showed that the Eurogroup can
help a country like Greece attain
degrees of freedom that are essential
for democracy and we have concluded that
this weekend is going to be a very hard
weekend but a very happy weekend because
we get a chance to get down to work not
to negotiate not to have to worry about
whether our point of is going to be hurt
but to get down to work in conjunction
with our partners and with institutions
who will be at an arm's length of course
we are going to be teleconferencing we
are going to sit down and codify in a
form of a table the reforms that this
government what's wants to institute
wants to implement and we'll have an
open line with our partners in the
institution's to exchange views because
we have a lot to learn from them because
you see this is the beauty of it once
you have a relationship of equals
instead of the relationship we used to
have the collaboration can be a lot more
fruitful and this weekend is going to be
such an occasion
we are living behind the days when a
list of reforms that Greek society
treated as a foreign body was imposed
but not implemented because it was a
foreign body as of today we're beginning
to be co-authors of our destiny
co-authors of the reforms that we want
to implement which we are going to
dictate which we will discuss with our
partners and which we are going to use
as a weapon against the deep
malignancies of the Greek social economy
which have been characterized in Greece
not for the last few years but for
decades if not a century malignancies
that we need to target successfully and
this is a great challenge if we're going
to reestablish greece's national
independence today if you look at the
communique the statement of the
Eurogroup we managed to avert a sequence
many years of suffocating primary
surpluses that our economy can simply
not produce without destroying the
productive basis of the private sector
you will see in the communique in the
statement that the Eurogroup very wisely
accepted the 2015 is a difficult year
because of the way it started and that
the primary surplus with that we shall
target which would be positive will
nevertheless be determined by the facts
on the ground by the genuine economic
circumstances that we face in which we
will assess together with our partners
as for the primary surpluses of the few
years to come which were at exorbitant
levels of four and a half five percent
for a London large number of years ahead
you will notice that the wording
includes a very good example of
constructive ambiguity
we are referring to appropriate primary
surpluses in line with previous
decisions and by that what we mean is
that we are going to contact our debt
sustainability analysis in conjunction
with the International Monetary Fund
which is very good at that and has
always over the last few years held
views with which I personally find
myself in in agreement with at the very
same time we're going to commit both
sides need to commit in an agreement but
this time I am pleased to report that
our commitments our commitments that we
will want to make anyway we committed
not to be changing any piece of
legislation or introducing unilateral
measures that will jeopardize economic
recovery financial stability and the
fiscal position of a government this is
a commitment which is actually pretty
good for us sometimes like Ulysses you
need to tie yourself on a must in order
to get where you're going and to avoid
the silence we put intend to do this we
have averted at the very same time
recessionary measures that were part of
the previous arrangement as you will see
there is no mention of any requirement
that we'll use pencils that we increase
v80 in the Aegean islands at the time
when tourism is picking up as the spring
is coming simultaneously with this
agreement we are putting together our
teams that will begin the long was not
that long medium term process of
negotiating what we call a future
contract for Greek recovery and growth a
contract between equals between the
Greek authorities our partners and the
institutions to commence after June
after this four-month period ends
with a view to growing ourselves out of
the crisis to the negotiating with our
partners ways of smartly restructuring
our debt in a way that allows both
greens to breathe more easily and to
repay in net present value terms more
money to our partners remember our task
is to maximize the prospects of the
European the average European citizen
not just of the average Greek and allow
me to finish by saying that today was a
pivotal moment because Greece which for
five years now during the bailout period
has been quite lonely in the Eurogroup
quite isolated we felt this isolation
the last couple of Europe's today that
isolation has broken today we have found
partners amongst those who up until very
recently looked at us with suspicion
there are some partners still that are
looking at us with suspicion this is our
challenge to win over their trust and we
intend to do this this is only a very
first step on a long journey but long
journeys have to be commenced with a
with a step the difference between this
step and previous steps is that this is
a step in the right direction thank you
very much